it took responders more than a day to
put out the fire a nation watched in
horror as nearly 100 Years of History
burned one of the Philippine capital's
most famous landmarks the Manila Central
post office was reduced to ruins if you
ask me what's the what's the biggest
loss
you will see it's the structure itself
but it wasn't the first time it suffered
complete destruction it was a casualty
of the battle of Manila during the
second world war officials have promised
to bring the heritage site back to its
Old Glory a feat achieved when it was
rebuilt in 1946
there's no demolition there's nothing's
going to happen in London Manila is one
of the oldest cities in the world but
remnants of its past are hard to find
under the law a building is considered a
cultural property if it's more than 50
years old and designed by a renowned
architect the Philippine Heritage Act of
2009 is meant to protect and preserve
Heritage structures like the Manila
Central post office
this hasn't always been the case
the Capital Theater located across the
river from the post office is almost
unrecognizable
in its Heyday in the 1930s it was state
of the art in an art deco Masterpiece
the government had approved the
construction of a high-rise but ordered
the Cinema's facade retained the
developers decided to tear it down last
year they retained a smidgen of the
tower right just to suggest that there
is a tower here but the rest of the
building is gone the building the
Capitol Theater cannot tell the story
anymore as eloquently as it could have
instead the Capital Theater has become a
symbol of the fight to preserve manila's
cultural heritage
when they aren't being demolished
historic structures are in disrepair
yet there's reason for optimism
the Manila Metropolitan theater was
recently restored after years of neglect
the impact of the Manila Central post
office fire
is so Broad and profound that we cannot
repeat our past mistakes
those mistakes include the lack of fire
prevention measures initial
investigation found the post office
building was not equipped with
sprinklers a widely used modern
firefighting system that could have
saved a National Treasure
point below Al Jazeera Manila